an apparent sea change in hong kong's
approach to covet 19. on monday its
chief executive kari lam announced the
city's border measures some of the
toughest in the world will finally be
relaxed a flight ban from nine countries
will be scrapped including the united
states the united kingdom india and
australia
this ban is no longer necessary because
the covenanted situation in these
countries is no worse than in hong kong
and many travelers coming here do not
have symptoms
quarantine will also be cut from 14 days
to one week for vaccinated travelers who
test negative
this only applies to residents tourists
are still unable to enter
plans to carry out city-wide testing are
also on hold
up until recently the city had been
pursuing a zero-tolerance policy to
stamping out the virus in line with
mainland china but that changed since
the number of cases increased
dramatically along with the death rate
no surprise because uh both the local
experts and also the uh experts from the
you know chinese cdc delegates we all in
nine uh of that
so we believe that we should focus on
increasing the vaccination rate
especially among the elderly
last week lamb conceded tolerance of the
severe measures was fading the tough
policy has also weighed on the economy
business leaders like alan zeeman have
warned the strict measures could have a
lasting impact on the city's status as a
financial hub
a host of other social distancing rules
are also set to be phased out in the
next month or so including the
two-person gathering limit and a dining
curfew
schools will go back to face-to-face
learning from next month a little bit of
the relax of the restriction is good
i don't agree with removing the flight
span covered 19 positive people are all
over the world if we allow people to
come here hong kong cannot deal with it
it's been a pain to all the hong kong
citizens i do feel relieved but
don't really trust the government that
much
i feel like she might change it again
soon lamb says the phasing out of social
distancing measures are dependent on
there being no resurgence of the virus
in the coming weeks and months brit
clinic al jazeera hong kong